this is not CGI
it's neither a Sci-Fi video game nor a
movie
this is the town of varkuda Russia and
it's all too real for the 70 000 people
who call it home
virtually everything about vorkuda
screams don't live here starting with
the extreme difficulty of getting there
nearly a hundred miles north of the
Arctic Circle it's the easternmost town
in Europe
with no roads in or out the only ways to
or from vorkuda are a 40-hour train ride
or one of the two to three weekly
flights assuming they're unimpeded by
blizzards
because of this those who move away are
liable to just leave behind their cars
and apartments with everything in them
which is how you get apocalyptic scenes
like these
during the winter temperatures can drop
as low as negative 58 degrees Fahrenheit
the Sun appears for just an hour on the
average December day
then after enduring this for eight long
months residents are rewarded with a
brief 70-day intermission when the snow
melts revealing the city's bright
soviet-era buildings underneath
clearly mother nature would prefer
vorcudo remain a vast untouched reindeer
sanctuary
so why does the city exist at all
what kind of person would move here
initially the kind who didn't have a
choice prisoners
chosen precisely for its isolation the
town was once home to one of the largest
and most notorious of the Soviet Union's
forced labor camps
later after Stalin's death and the end
of the gulag Moscow invested billions of
rubles transforming distant Arctic
settlements like vorkuda into shining
triumphant symbols of the empire
conquering nature was no less apolitical
as a practical project
like Mao's obsession with dams vorcuda
and places like it were irrefutable
physical Testaments to the power of
socialism
these towns some though not all in
Siberia were usually designed around a
single industry sometimes even a single
Factory
in vorkuda that industry was coal mining
further south another one produces
asbestos
in fact the town is named after the
known carcinogen which it still mines to
this day
in total there are about 300 Russian
mono towns of which vorkuda is neither
the furthest North most remote nor even
the coldest
take for example nerilsk a nickel mine
masquerading as a city of 200 000 people
entry is strictly off limits to
foreigners which may be a good thing
considering it's one of the world's most
polluted cities
it's hazy Brown air and toxic discolored
water make vorkuda by comparison look
like Disneyland
despite this thousands pack their bags
and cheerfully moved to places like
norilsk and vorkuda in the 70s and 80s
thanks to the Soviet system of social
welfare
although the retirement age was set very
generously at just 55 for women and 60
for men you could retire even earlier
and collect an even larger pension if
you met certain conditions
conditions like working in a mine or
better yet working in a mine in the
middle of nowhere
that placed for Cuda right in the
bullseye of the Venn diagram
young Russians could move to the Arctic
do a few years of hard labor and then
retire early down on the Crimean Beach
but all that came to an end on Christmas
Day 1991.
the collapse of the Soviet Union meant
the collapse of the entire economic
model on which these mono towns were
based
suddenly these mines factories and power
plants were thrown out to the Wolves
forced to fend for themselves on the
global market
after a lifetime of artificial State
support how could they possibly compete
so what happened next was as predictable
as it was tragic
bankruptcies led to layoffs layoffs led
to Poverty poverty to crime and crime to
mass migration
a quarter of vorkuda fled in the four
years between 1998 and 2002.
meanwhile the 1998 financial crisis had
reduced the value of Russian pensions by
nearly 50 percent
in short seniors were on the verge of
financial ruin
what little social welfare remained was
often inconsistent or ineffective
retired teachers might be entitled to
free bus rides where public transit no
longer existed
these but not those veterans might be
granted free phone service
Etc
this was the Russia that Vladimir Putin
inherited at the turn of the millennium
the entire social welfare system was in
dire need of an overhaul
and his first attempt to fix it was
called the monetization of benefits
rather than maintain 230 different
complex outdated categories of benefits
the idea was why not just give people
cash and let them decide what to do with
it
in truth it was a fairly modest proposal
with entirely reasonable intentions
but the government failed to communicate
its plan effectively
what's more the Kremlin delegated
implementation to individual regions
leading to Geographic disparities
Russians everywhere from downtown Saint
Petersburg to rural Siberia were Furious
thousands of protesters descended on the
streets shouting down with Putin and
waving nostalgic Soviet Flags
in their eyes this was not a mere change
in policy it was nothing less than a
giant middle finger to their years of
hard labor and national service
these coal miners traveled all the way
from vorkuda to protest in the streets
of Moscow
that's like swimming from Guam to the
White House lawn
for Putin the message was loud and clear
don't touch pensions or anything
resembling pensions with a 10-foot Pole
pensioners became a critical base of
support for his party United Russia
in 2005 on the subject of raising the
retirement age Putin declared
unequivocally on television quote this
decision will not be taken while I am
president
he later called pensions the Soviet
Union's greatest achievement
and after seeing how the issue of social
welfare inspired political interest even
in Siberian coal miners his government
paid particular attention to these
remote decaying mono towns home to a
large number of retirees
the Kremlin was so concerned that it
tasked the Federal Protective Service
Russia's equivalent to the Secret
Service with conducting quote
sociological surveys
these undercover agents identified 54
mono towns as having the greatest risk
of unrest with another 104 not far
behind
thus while other ex-communist countries
like Poland and Hungary encouraged the
residents of the Rust Belt towns to
slowly migrate toward jobs Russia saw
them as delicate kindling waiting for
the tiniest spark to ignite a wildfire
less risky to Simply keep these dying
regions on life support handing out just
enough busy work to ensure scarce time
for any extracurricular activities
these factories may not produce anything
tangible of value but what they do
produce are votes for United Russia
High Employment Plus Rising pensions
equals Harmony
the first way it achieves this harmony
is with a wildly bloated bureaucracy
in 2011 nearly 20 percent of the entire
National Labor Force was employed by the
state
and that's not counting state-owned
companies another 12 percent
in fact the pension fund itself employs
over a hundred thousand people sixty
percent more than its American
counterpart despite serving a population
half as large
you know there's a problem when the
American government looks like an
efficient well-oiled Machine by
comparison
[Music]
secondly the Kremlin collaborates with
or more accurately threatens businesses
oligarchs may be given an incredibly
Long Leash in Russia but one red line
they definitely don't dare cross are
excessive layoffs
shut down an unprofitable Factory in a
politically sensitive area and you might
suddenly develop a dangerous habit of
falling out of Windows
when times are tough oligarchs wisely
try just about anything under the sun
before resorting to layoffs including
deferring paychecks slowing down
Recruitment and giving workers unplanned
extended holidays
finally mono towns are directly
subsidized in 2010 alone 846 million US
dollars were allocated to 27 towns
that's how the Kremlin keeps Baseline
dissatisfaction low
but Putin also sprinkles in some sweet
carrots particularly before an important
election
as you can see pensions have increased
substantially since the year 2000. they
more than doubled between 2012 and 22.
now Russian pensions have never been
large the average amount is only 222 US
dollars a month
but remember this is a country where the
mean annual income is about eight
thousand dollars
for 93 of its 46 million pensioners this
is the only thing keeping them from
extreme poverty
to call these retirees single issue
voters is a massive understatement
either they receive these pensions or
they starve it's that simple
and given the sheer size of this voting
block one-third of the whole country
Putin's extraordinarily High approval
should be no surprise
over the course of his career Putin
perfected this high employment Rising
pension social harmony formula
but this incredible success was
deceiving
beneath this Band-Aid the infection was
getting worse a lot worse
and to see why we need to take a brief
step back
in their simplest form the way pensions
work is that one group pays into a giant
pool of money and another group
withdraws out of that same pool of money
in other words the whole concept
requires a balance of payers and payees
this is what that balance looked like
before the Soviet Union collapsed
the 1991 population broken down by age
from Young at the bottom to Old on top
better yet let's ignore the kids combine
everyone age 20 to 54 into one
contributor group and anyone older into
a single recipient group
take it all in and now compare that 1991
balance to this 2021 balance
as you can see the Soviet Union was
playing welfare on easy mode with much
fewer recipients
immediately after its fall the number of
new births collapsed and for every one
of the last 32 years since Russia has
gotten considerably older tilting
pensions off balance with 44 percent
more recipients and slightly fewer
contributors
the writing has been on the wall for
three decades the math simply doesn't
add up
and there's no doubt Putin knew this
but to peel back the Band-Aid and
confront the root cause would mean
risking a larger potentially regime
threatening version of what happened
back in 2004.
so he waited and waited and waited until
the inevitable could be delayed no
longer
to regain balance the recipient group
had to shrink in the contributor group
had to grow which meant Putin had to do
what he vowed never to do 13 years
earlier on television raise the
retirement age
this time however he had a plan
on June 14 2018 while Russian soccer
fans were busy cheering their defeat of
Saudi Arabia on the opening day of the
World Cup Putin made his move the
retirement age was quietly increased
from 60 to 65 for men and from 55 to 63
for women
with this one change the Russian
retirement age went from one of the
world's most generous unchanged since
its establishment by Joseph Stalin in
the early 1900s to one of the world's
least generous
to make matters worse these changes were
implemented much faster than in most
countries
the United States for example is very
slowly raising its retirement age by
just two years in total over the course
of two decades
needless to say this was not well
received
this is Putin's popularity since 1999
and this 15 drop in approval is when the
announcement was made
in days Putin lost most of the surge in
support he gained from the annexation of
Crimea in 2014.
this was in fact the largest short-term
collapse in approval he's ever seen
before or since
and by January the Public's level of
trust in Putin fell to just 33 percent
with a full 50 preferring the
resignation of his cabinet
the backlash was so intense that his
administration eventually lowered the
retirement age again this time from 63
to 60 for women
though this concession failed to address
one of the most common complaints a huge
number of Russians will never see a dime
earlier we saw this population pyramid
dividing the country into age groups
but this graph obscures a massive
imbalance
to see it we have to split each age
cohort by gender
in case it's still unclear let's show
only the excess men or women for each
age group
notice the pattern down here men very
slightly outnumber women
here between ages 30 and 34 the two
groups are roughly equal and then from
there women start to rapidly Eclipse men
by the time you reach age 70 there are
three women for every one man
the simple unfortunate reality is that
Russian men don't live very long
poor health care physically arduous
labor plus off the charts alcohol
consumption will do that
to be clear its life expectancy has
increased substantially in recent years
credit where credit is due but that
comes after Decades of decline
you heard that right between 1960 and 94
the average Russian lost three years of
their life
but that's both men and women the male
life expectancy is dramatically lower a
mere 66 years today
and even that's just a national average
in poor rural regions the male life
expectancy is much much lower
remember norilsk from earlier its life
expectancy is 59 and almost certainly
lower for men most of whom work in
nickel mines
that leaves its average resident with a
retirement of negative six years
even the average Russian male can only
expect a year
so you can probably see why the 2018
change wasn't met with Glee
now I won't bore you with the
implications of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine the pandemic which overwhelmed
its already underfunded Health Care
system or the Western sanctions on all
manner of its exports but suffice to say
whatever demographic and fiscal problems
the country had five years ago things
are much worse now
the beautiful thing about demographics
is that they allow you to peer into the
future
there are fewer Russian teenagers today
so there will be fewer pension fund
contributors tomorrow
but the devastating thing about
demographics is that for the most part
they're fixed
today's teenagers are 13 year old
ripples of actions passed unless Putin
invents a time machine or immigrants
flock to a country whose passport is
becoming less powerful by the day
there's no short-term solution
the ratio of all to Young will only
continue to grow Shifting the pension
balance ever more precariously toward a
large number of seniors which means the
2018 change won't be the last
sooner or later Putin will be forced to
confront reality
this is not unique to Russia far from it
most of Europe has it even worse pension
protests will soon become a regular
feature of the global news cycle
but there's one critical difference
take a second look at Putin's approval
rating now consider everything Russians
have tolerated during these 24 years
election fraud a failing education
system rampant corruption crackdowns on
civil society Rising inflation and most
recently a draft
and yet throughout all of it Putin
maintained an average approval of 74
percent
the one thing that did move the needle
or pensions
no retiree in any corner of the globe
favors a decrease in their income of
course but only Russian retirees have
put up with so much in exchange
take away pensions and the trade becomes
everything for nothing
take away pensions and the entire social
contract supporting the modern Russian
State falls apart
that is the challenge facing Putin
he might find some solutions with the
help of chat GPT if only he had access
to this class on today's sponsor
skillshare about how to use large
language models effectively you might
think as I did that since the whole
point of an AI is to understand your
request you don't need to learn how to
use it but chat GPT is merely a tool and
like any tool there are tricks and
techniques you can employ to produce a
better result when I started getting
more strategic with my prompts I
instantly went from chat GPT skeptic to
believer and this class can do the same
for you whether you plan on using it
professionally or merely for fun
this is just one of thousands of courses
you can find on skillshare including my
courses in which I show you how I make
these videos now watched by over 23 000
people an annual subscription costs less
than 10 bucks a month but the first 1000
people to join with the link on screen
get a one month free trial thanks to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
foreign